[Música]
aquí hoy este viernes 5 de julio para
presentarles este programa canadá en las
américas cable el preferido de todos hoy
en compañía de leonora chapman leonardo
sin menú y luis laborda pablo gómez
barrios acá de este lado y este programa
se esto están escuchando en directo por
youtube facebook live en nuestro sitio
internet r 6 puntos ya y nuestra
aplicación
leonora leonardo luis bienvenidos al
triple la triple no suele suceder muy a
menudo pablo y la triple pero de vez en
cuando sucede mal que les suena feo eso
de la triple a
pero recuerde las 13 entonces prefiero
bueno un caluroso saludo a todos ustedes
allá del otro lado del micrófono y de
las cámaras es verdaderamente bueno muy
muy muy contento de estar acá estamos
todos muy contentos de estar aquí
[Música]
deseamos un momento ameno aquí con
nosotros
hay algunas notas algunos aspectos que
vamos a abordar antes de comenzar y
darle rienda suelta a este programa a
canadá en las américas café y es que
este viernes es el último día del último
programa por durante cuatro semanas hace
unas semanas de vacaciones a las
vacaciones estivales y vamos a estar
entonces fuera de ondas el 12 el 19 el
26 de julio y el 2 de agosto
entonces les advertimos para que no
vayan a sentirse defraudados cuando
solos y sólo parados pueden volver a ver
los antiguos programas
yo había pensado en eso pero desde
nuestro lado hacer una redifusión de
antiguos sino lo que yo había pensado en
el momento era hacer una edición de los
momentos más graciosas pero algunas
veces porque nosotros somos muy notables
de los libros por ejemplo así bueno los
vídeos es una cosa y hay otras cosas más
de las que podríamos hablar hay también
vídeos island y si es así yo por mi lado
son vídeos allá por su lado es vídeos
bueno pero es otro como el comer fideos
comiendo fideos bueno otra otra cosita
que me gustaría recordarles es que la
última vez justamente que yo estuve
presentando este programa tuvimos
invitados
eran los dos escritores que presentaron
el libro historias de montreal
ese día hicimos un sorteo sorteamos dos
libros los ganadores fueron césar
augusto charlie rodríguez charlize de
bogotá colombia y serín solimán de bull
de vettel en la isla del príncipe
eduardo yo personalmente no he tenido
ninguna confirmación le enviamos los
libros
creo que ella dijo en facebook que había
recibido y daba las gracias o que porque
yo no vi de haber leído eso bueno
césar cercenadas rodríguez harris y
bueno si recibiste el libro césar por
favor podemos sabemos juntar dos
secciones en unas y que nos manden una
foto o un vídeo cada uno de ellos y
ellos mismos mostrando el libro leyendo
el libro sería fantástico ponemos una
sugerencia de nuestro querido para
soplador de los paisajes de colombia y
realizar el príncipe eduardo
con el libro
telephone de saque
pues me parece fantástico bueno es eran
los puntos que yo quería señalar antes
de darle rienda suelta al programa pero
leonardo tú tienes
miriam alarcón dice hola los voy a
extrañar por el contenido de sus notas y
ese es mucho tiempo cuatro semanas y
pone un pequeño emoticón con las
lágrimas porque no estamos la próxima
podemos convencerlo al jefe que hagamos
los programas
[Aplausos]
no hay suficiente gente para trabajar
cierto las vacaciones sí bueno entonces
algo que se ha vuelto una costumbre acá
en este programa es hablar de algunas
cosas insólitas
de noticias o de programas o de temas
que hayan traído llamado nuestra
atención y yo creo que para este
programa caería bien yo creo que todo lo
está haciendo acá que además hay una
advertencia de ola de calor importante
asesor vivo y sobre todo con el factor
de unidad para llegar a los 43 grados
que eso a veces uno dice haga como como
dijo a alguien creo que en facebook eso
no es nada yo vivo dijo 38 39 nada yo
vivo permanentemente con 45 es como
decirle a una persona en el caribe es
hoy de enelvén pleno invierno va a ser
cinco grados bajo cero en tal lugar del
caribe
nadie está acostumbrado a ese tipo
cuando empiezan a sentirse acá en canadá
decir que va a ser 42 con el factor es
muchísimo calor para la gente que vive
acá en el país
aquí cuando poco después del mediodía o
las primeras horas de la tarde me
impactó el calor que hacía el verano a
mí me gusta no me gusta el calor y
cuando hace mucho calor no me molesta
tanto como cuando hace mucho frío y
independientemente de eso hay gente que
tiene digamos menos tolerancia con
respecto al calor y sobre todo la
humedad ese es el problema yo creo aquí
en montreal no tanto el calor porque el
calor no hace mucho el calor van a hacer
34 35 grados 39 no pero más la sensación
térmica 39 40 y 41
digamos
violento no nos olvidemos en el 2018
2017 han muerto 66 personas en montreal
por el calor
claro pero la gente aquí en montreal y
sobre todo la gente mayor está muy bien
digamos educadas con el frío cuando hace
frío no salen cuando hace frío no se
mueven cuando hace frío
los van a buscar los llevan nos traen
con el calor es lindo o sea uno no tiene
ese tipo de precauciones que debería
tenerlas pero no solamente precauciones
no están acostumbrados recordar que hace
apenas unos diez días atrás hablábamos
un artículo que en este caso hice yo de
el problema que estaba habiendo en el
este de canadá con el tema del calor y
la gente en las provincias marítimas por
ejemplo que está acostumbrada a
temperaturas promedio que no sobrepasan
largamente los 15 grados entonces cuando
esa gente le presentase el pronóstico de
un día a más de 30 o 35 no se trata de
de educación o de costumbre físicamente
no están preparados y no tienen la
infraestructura para hacer frente a
mucha gente en el este de canadá por
ejemplo no cuenta con aire acondicionado
en su casa porque nunca lo han
necesitado entonces cuando llega una ola
de calor como está algunos de aquellos
que no tienen aire acondicionado su casa
llevo encerrado todo el año por el resto
del año digamos por el por el invierno o
sea ahora aunque sufre un poco de la
humedad entre comidas porque lo que más
me golpea sodio entonces tengo para
ustedes para nosotros es fácil porque
venimos de países cálidos es mucho más
fácil que alguien que vive en un país
nórdico desde generaciones y hablar de
hablar de aire acondicionado me da
urticaria así porque es que aquí en esta
casa mira yo tengo que tener un suéter
encima porque la temperatura es tan baja
a cabo en algunos les gusta el contraste
pero cuando sales de aquí va al exterior
te pueden enfriar
no no tengo tampoco aire acondicionado
en casa pero vamos a hablar de cambiar
de tema porque el tema es la copa
américa cambiamos de tema hablemos del
calor
[Risas]
[Música]
de la concacaf la copa oro una solista
argentina decía porque va a ser apoyadas
pobres animales no hablemos de eso
dijimos que eso que la pasó hablando de
la copa américa
el líder del equipo femenino de eeuu la
que tiene el pelito corto que no me va a
cortar la anti trump la que rechazó la
invitación de de trump para ir a la casa
blanca y que atrás le dijo tiene que
ganar algo antes de hablar conmigo la
chica ganó todo cuando dijo estaba
leyendo hacia ahora decía que protestaba
porque la copa américa la final y la
final del mundial de fútbol de mujeres
es el mismo día me imagino que está
protestando no sé si es porque es a la
misma hora espero que no sea la misma
hora
no yo creo que es a horas distintas pero
de todas maneras este año hubo una
conjunción y un alineamiento de astro
camper holísticos que hizo que varios
campeonatos la copa américa la copa
ahora la razón por la cual estaba a
qatar y japón en la copa américa es
porque la copa oro se jugaba al mismo
tiempo y los equipos que usualmente que
se invitan que la conmebol invita para
llenar el cupo de los dos que se
necesitan para tener 12 equipos y no
ellos no podían pero no siempre no
siempre yo creo que de que no fuese
solamente es el motivo por el cual no
invitaron gente la concacaf porque no
todos los años invitan gente la concacaf
invitan un asiático seguro porque el
fútbol latinoamericano vende muchísimo
porque marc carísimo porque más
ganadores al que le da dinero a la
conmebol
el otro bueno dependiendo por ahí es
méxico por ahí
otro país bueno en este caso era con de
la concacaf o por ahí
en este caso eligieron a catar porque
son los que los hospedan el próximo
mundial es centro entonces bueno hubo la
copa mundial femenina de fútbol de la
que tú estabas hablando la final
suecia va a ser un partidazo la copa
africana eeuu o la noruega holanda
holanda holanda perdón la copa de áfrica
de la que nadie hable y también se está
llevando a cabo todos los equipos
africanos compitiendo entre sí y bueno
ya no quedan tanto como va
estoy perdido no ha seguido ningún
torneo en esta ocasión
pero entonces la final de la copa
américa
una noticia eso para mí
en realidad les voy a contar una
realidad vi dos pie dos de los cuatro
tiene vídeos raro en mí como él decía en
raro en mí es raro me haber visto sólo
dos de los de todos los partidos juegos
no probablemente este fin de semana me
voy de cámping-gas y que igualmente
probablemente sentido estás triste
porque chile por el tercer puesto
yo por ejemplo mi caso yo vi dos
partidos de argentina y la verdad tuve
que hacer esfuerzo para no dormirme
brasil
y te dormiste también elevaron a no
exageres louis no era lo menos no pero
igual o sea porque yo estoy muy
desconforme con en realidad la
asociación de fútbol argentino porque
dicen que se está haciendo una
reestructuración en la selección
argentina y la reestructuración no es en
la selección se tiene que hacer desde la
base del fuego argentino en la
asociación de fútbol argentino sino
parte de ahí es siempre lo mismo es
siempre lo mismo ahora como están
quebrados porque no tienen un centavo
porque le siguen pagando el contrato
millonario al ex director técnico
sampaoli porque el contrato decía que
había que pagarla durante los años
porque lo sacaron lo echaron de no crean
por eso ahora está lionel scaloni que
les sale relativamente barato por eso no
hay un director técnico de prestigio con
lo que se necesita de vamos alguien
puede firmar un contrato de esa manera
esa es la respuesta a la afa hace esas
cosas entonces hasta que no haya una
reestructuración del fútbol argentino
este año por ejemplo no sentí la pasión
de otros años el año pasado por ejemplo
no sé con rusia en rusia está muy
apasionado en la copa américa centenario
que se realizó el viaje a boston a ver
un partido argentina o sea y este año
fue como la edad están madurando
no creo que políticamente hablando
pongámosle que queda bien decir gracias
pero me en serio tiene que ver con eso
digamos no sea la necesidad de un cambio
estructural que no será por cuestiones
políticas o vaya a saber que entonces
hasta que no pase el fútbol nuestro base
estructural y generacional porque se
sigue dependiendo de supuestas estrellas
que hasta el momento en la selección no
han demostrado gran cosa y que de todas
maneras incluso ya a nivel equipos están
en el límite de su edad profesional
hay que ir pensando también en otra
generación que renueve al fútbol
argentino
que renueve al fútbol de la selección y
que le vuelva a dar el brillo que la
selección argentina tuvo durante décadas
sobre ese tema yo por ejemplo el
recambio estructural desde jugadores yo
considero que se puede hacer lo que hizo
brasil brasil no sacó a todas sus
estrellas impulsó los nuevos de un solo
hizo un mix primero y fue cambiando
paulatinamente está bien por pro porque
tenían un plan de trabajo argentina no
lo tiene el plan trabajo entonces cuando
hablamos de esta generación que no le ha
dado mucho la selección le dio tres
subcampeonatos usar tres finales no y
que dice que estaba esperando que lo
llamen y no lo va a ver gallardo ni el
cholo simeone sexuales y me dijo si
alguna vez estoy va a ser el final de mi
carrera
vale normalmente espero pero la copa
américa en argentina colombia hablemos
de color ya mí tampoco me sorprendió que
me sorprendió que animes órdenes perdía
ya perdido con perú pero me sorprendió
me sorprendió como modifica la jugada y
cómo se modifica a gusto y placer de la
la la
la utilización del bar con uruguay con
uruguay
chile también brasil fueron 22 partidos
dos penales no cobrados cuando juego
contra venezuela en el partido contra
argentina hubo una falta después que
hubo un penal ninguna de esas dos cosas
fueron cobradas después vino el segundo
gol de brasil hubiera estado a 1 a 1
en el primer tiempo y no lo estuvo
porque no se revisó al bar entonces
cuáles son las decisiones siempre el
árbitro no le puede imponer a la gira
retro considera que él tiene los
elementos suficientes como para
desconocer la observación que le está
haciendo el bar
con el bar y que los jugadores no
estaban de acuerdo en la discusión de
nunca acabar
bueno entonces chile perú chile te
sorprendió la gran final yo como buen
argentino espera del perú
brasil perú en realidad como un
argentino prefiero que me de perú porque
brasil es nuestro nuestro rival de toda
la vida pero bueno el fútbol no se sabe
para mí si estaba para pasar bueno y qué
bien que le va los canadienses en
wimbledon
raonic pasó ya la cuarta ronda y esta
tarde juega el muchachito este de 18
años félix
el joven quebequense canadiense que está
dando que hablar ahí en todo el mundo
así que interesante tanto las
canadienses en wimbledon que tiene todos
esta carga de prestigio no exactamente y
leonora para salir un poco del fútbol e
irnos introduciendo un poco más en el
programa tú tenías una
un comentario sobre un reloj de
población en canadá
si eso es justo y eso es un reportaje
que hice hoy y que me pareció muy
interesante se trata de una herramienta
inventada creada por estadísticas canadá
que permite seguir minuto a minuto el
cambio demográfico que se está
produciendo en canadá no sé si podemos
ver un poco los los gráficos o lo
dejamos para después académicas y
podemos hablar de este otro tema si
conoces y prefieres este sobre una
investigación y medio ambiente que se
hizo aquí en canadá
y es una investigación que fue dirigida
y realizada por el consejo de academias
canadienses que es un grupo formado por
eminencias a nivel de james y académicos
a nivel de medio ambiente y que ellos
concluyeron hicieron como una especie de
reducción de los peligros del medio
ambiente que están en estos momentos
pueden producirse en canadá y de los
cincuenta y pico de elementos que pueden
producir daño dan se han rescatado los
seis más importantes y entonces seis más
importantes en primer lugar se encuentra
el concluyeron ellos que la manera en
que están construidos los edificios en
canadá suponen un problema para por
ejemplo la erosión de las costas el agua
las lluvias en fin todo lo que puede el
calor todo lo que puede afectar a las
construcciones canadá no está muy
preparado para hacer frente a esos
niveles de edificios en segundo lugar
no sé si hay fotos pablo de estas no no
creo
ok y después del segundo el segundo
problema que detectaron los científicos
era el nivel de las costas el avance de
las aguas y cómo se van erosionando las
costas y el tercer problema que ellos
detectaron se encuentran las comunidades
del norte que son las que están
sufriendo más en este momento el
problema del deshielo entonces lo que es
interesante también desde reportajes
esos esos tres elementos principales que
ellos destacan pero también abordan las
soluciones bueno excelente leonardo hay
algún comentario si tenemos un
comentario en este caso de gustavo lucas
son uno de nuestros top panes de uruguay
de uruguay sí señor saludos de la ciudad
de melo en uruguay en realidad dice
aunque en este momento estoy en la
ciudad de yaguarón en brasil a 90
kilómetros de melo así que desde ahí
está sintonizando exacto nuestro viento
no escucha viendo nos escucha viéndonos
exacto bueno muy bien vamos a dar una
vuelta por los comentarios que tenemos
por ahí represados
en nuestro sitio internet en louis tú
tienes por ahí alguno a la mano sí señor
tengo uno que nos envía alexander cruz
sobre el tema una pequeña ciudad
canadiense que quiere acoger al gran
número de migrantes él dice hola soy
cocinero mi esposa es tecnólogo en
contaduría pública tengo dos hijos de
siete y cuatro años respectivamente
deseamos una mejor calidad de vida para
nosotros la rivière nos encanta como
posible ciudad para emigrar qué
posibilidades hay y qué forma para
hacerlo agradezco la información bueno
nuestro river fue referida a no mucho
tiempo atrás como una de las ciudades
más interesantes e insisten dentro de lo
que es la religión en la región
de la provincia de québec y han hablado
en bar una vez funcionarios incluso de
la municipalidad de tu aliviar diciendo
la cantidad de posibilidades laborales
que esa ciudad que ya no es tan pequeña
alberga pero como decimos siempre en el
caso de estos temas en materia de
inmigración la única fuente de
información o la mejor fuente de
información
más fiable es siempre dirigirse al
ministerio de inmigración en este caso
puede ser el provincial de la provincia
de québec y ahí va a encontrar todo lo
que tiene que ver con los requisitos
para inmigrar para el me para venir
hacia canadá luego primero y luego verá
cuál es la forma que llega a sentarse o
de ponerse en contacto con las
posibilidades laborales que existen en
asia de la rivière pero nosotros no
podemos ofrecerles más datos que los
mejores datos que les puede ofrecer el
ministerio de inmigración respectivo y
las embajadas en sus respectivos países
que también les pueden informar a ese
respecto se ha clonado si yo aquí tengo
uno que dice canadá eligió 11
comunidades rurales y del norte que
acogerán inmigración en el otoño en 2019
y rafael farías en la misma la misma
línea que el mensaje de louis dice
buenas tardes por favor cómo hago para
postular no hay información clara sobre
cómo se aplica desde colombia muchas
gracias y no hay información clara
porque nosotros no estamos dando la
información para que éste aplique
estamos dando a conocer cuál es en este
caso la política nada
es posible hacer
canadá inmediata en quebec puntos o sea
iban a entrar el proceso es siempre el
mismo en el caso de los lugares donde
hay una delegación de quebec abierta
puede iniciarse un 112 un legajo
a través de la delegación de que verón
para postular a emigrar a la provincia
luego ese mismo legajo pasa a la
embajada canadiense la embajada
canadiense solicita toda la información
respectiva el proceso demanda según el
país entre uno y varios años hay algunos
países en los que demanda varios años de
completarse en la mayoría de los casos
el proceso normal dura alrededor de un
año un año y medio pero las embajadas
por un lado y la delegación de quebec
donde donde existe porque no hay en
todos los países son las fuentes más
fiables son las primeras la única puerta
el mejor dicho- para iniciar un proceso
de inmigración a canadá no hay otra vía
entonces lo mejor es entrar a las
páginas de esos organismos de las
embajadas y las delegaciones e
informarse a través de eso
a veces solemos poner también enlaces al
final ya que los puede ayudar yo puse en
un artículo que publiqué hace
aproximadamente tres semanas atrás los
vínculos al ministerio de inmigración de
cada una de las provincias canadienses
así que si buscan esa nota ahí tienen
los vínculos respectivos lo buscan por
nombre pueden poner luis laborda y en
nuestro sitio internet van a tener la
información leonora si yo tengo acá un
comentario sobre el tema es que ve que
suecia noruega brasil gran bretaña
uruguay-chile lo hicieron acá nada se
resiste hay un comentario de césar
carrasco que dice muy buen reportaje el
problema es serio acá de lo que se
trataba este reportaje es que hay una
petición que está circulando y que ya
fue aprobada en primera instancia por el
parlamento canadiense donde se le pide
al gobierno de canadá que prohíba a
nivel canadiense pan canadiense que haya
publicidad en los programas infantiles
publicidad de comida chatarra jugos y lo
que fuera que está causando un serio
problema de los chicos acá canadiense y
que además eso después los adolescentes
continúan y así lado besora de edad
aumentando en canadá y que ver lo hizo
quiere decir que ve que ya desde hace
mucho tiempo prohibió la publicidad en
los programas de los niños de cualquier
alimento chatarra entonces sí que beck
lo hizo canadá podría hacerlo pero lo
que dice el entrevistado acá es que hay
mucha presión de la industria
alimentaria para impedir que eso ocurra
porque las grandes ganancias vienen en
los supermercados los supermercados
ahora para la mayoría de los mercados no
es canadienses o de las de las grandes
tiendas que audiencias tienen como
pasillos para entrar las cajas en los
pasillos está rodeado de góndolas del
tamaño nos superan digamos yo parado
digamos a mi pecho de cosas para los
niños claro uno cuando va con los niños
están a la altura turista y claro le
piden piden bien pero se ha demostrado
en lo que explicaba el invitado en este
momento está demostrado que la tasa de
obesidad la menor
de obesidad en los niños en canadá está
en quebec y piensan que es el hecho de
que no haya publicidad en los programas
infantiles de acá juega un papel lo y
seguro que juega un papel seguro yo creo
que efectivamente aparte el otro día leí
un artículo que hablaba sobre la manera
en que la gente presenta a las
publicidades y están absolutamente
enfocadas
a los niños los colores que les gustan
las palabras que usan las palabras que
entienden la velocidad para hablar lás
osea hay todo un gran estudio detrás de
estos y como dice leonora es muy
probable que en ese caso adrián haga un
gran pérdida de dinero entonces por eso
era porque el senado canadiense tenía
que tratar el tema y no lo trató y pasó
al receso y ahora viene una elección en
canadá
así que exacto por eso había
preocupación bueno leonardo dije otros
seguimos insistiendo con nuestra
aplicación así que seguimos insistiendo
más lo prometemos vamos a hablar de la
aplicación en realidad les vamos a
mostrar un poquito de qué se trata la
aplicación
es ha sido creada hace no mucho tiempo
hace un par de meses en realidad es la
aplicación de radio canal internacional
donde usted tiene toda la información
que encuentra en nuestro sitio de una
manera mucho más rápida y una manera más
condensada en la presentación en
realidad y está separada por distintas
categorías tenemos en cartelera política
sociedad inmigración refugiados y otras
más usted a partir de la aplicación en
español puede ir directamente al francés
o al inglés ahí estamos viendo un poco
cómo se no se ve la parte de arriba que
es donde está el menú pero ahí está el
menú y usted puede hasta ver nuestros
formatos largos por ejemplo que es la
oferta de entrevistas y reportajes que
tienen bastante más
con extensión y contenido que lo que
producimos normalmente hay en nuestros
periodistas hacen
un extraordinario trabajo bueno están
todos así condensados así que la persona
que quiera puede ir a nuestro sitio
internet en el sitio internet a la
derecha arriba está la publicidad de la
aplicación hacen clic ahí van a caer una
página donde tienen la opción de ir
tanto a la tienda de apple como la
tienda de android para bajar la
aplicación correspondiente a cada uno de
sus teléfonos toma 20 segundos hacerlo y
realmente le da a uno la libertad de por
ejemplo yo quiero leer estás
por ejemplo este formato largo de
sobreviviente de trata sexual a
ultramaratonista y activista excepcional
hago clic y está todo el contenido es
más puedo guardar el contenido para
después puedo cambiar si no puedo yo que
tengo a ti gmat ismo y un poquito de un
poquito de presbicia
programa del alma
así que bueno ahí pueden estar toda la
entrevista del formato largo es
realmente muy fácil muy comida pueden
hacerlo en cualquier momento toma 30
segundos máximo para bajar esta
aplicación así que se la recomendamos y
los invitamos fuertemente a que bajen la
aplicación y la experimenten con los
teléfonos inteligentes y todas las
tabletas bueno excelente probaste sí muy
bien y ahora la invitación también que
hemos hecho a menudo es
y enviarnos fotos de hablarnos del lugar
donde están viviendo fotos y 6 leer
etcétera y hay una persona que ha
respondido a ese llamado ya hemos pasado
la semana pasada o la anterior algunas
fotos que no envió se trata de daniel
camporini desde monroe en argentina en
la provincia de buenos aires y esta vez
el 2 envió si podemos pasar a las fotos
él nos envió una serie de fotos desde
hoy en uruguay y de tierra del fuego él
dice siempre he pensado que los extremos
del continente tiene mucho en común
especialmente en su geografía estas
fotos son de la isla de tierra del fuego
la provincia más austral de la argentina
cuya capital es ushuaia la ciudad más
austral del mundo la geografía de la
isla es abrumadora por su belleza el
canal del beagle
une ambos océanos sus parques nacionales
las pingüineras es un poco las fotos que
estamos viendo en este momento el tren
del fin del mundo desaparece cada
antigua prisión hoy deseo los barcos
encallados en la tierra de aventuras
etcétera etcétera entonces pues él dice
finalmente
un hermoso sitio de la argentina que
vale la pena
a usted yo nunca estuve una vez en
ushuaia
la primera foto que veíamos en la
prisión de ushuaia que se llama o es
llamada popularmente la prisión del fin
del mundo que hoy en día el museo como
dice la información que te envío
camporini en donde estuvieron detenidos
más de un expresidente argentino y que
fue el lugar de grandes fugas
pero de grandes fugas de situación
evasión es en el fin del mundo en la
cárcel del fin del mundo
entonces pues agradecemos inmensamente a
danielle camporini por estas fotos que
nos envió y los invitamos a ustedes a
que nos envíen fotos también del lugar
donde están viviendo de su barrio
etcétera si pueden enviarnos también un
corto vídeo muy bien
aquí para que no así que nos pueden
enviar eso a nuestro sitio y nosotros
con un gran placer lo pasaremos aquí en
este programa no solamente del exterior
desde canadá también hay lugares de
canadá que nos interesa conocer que
nosotros mismos que vivimos aquí no los
conocemos lo voy a hacer de la realidad
va a ser para después de las vacaciones
pero porque hay que recordar la gente
vamos a estar de vacaciones cuatro
semanas a partir de la que viene
voy a hacer fotos o pequeños vídeos del
camping donde bien este fin de semana es
donde en la diabla
así que yo voy a ir también al mont
tremblant no en el sector de la diabla
pero en otro sector por ahí cerca
también así que podemos traer tres
vídeos
o vídeos y un vídeo para los campistas
los cámpines
leonardo tenemos algún mensaje de
nuestra
linux y teníamos acá gustavo luca que se
les deseo felices vacaciones que
disfruten gracias
justamente hablando de estas pequeñas
vacaciones que se va a tomar el programa
durante las próximas cuatro semanas así
que esos son los mensajes que tenemos
hasta el momento y de no hacer los
mensajes escritos luis laborda
muchísimos muchísimos tengo uno aquí que
nos envía rené gutiérrez méndez sobre
canadá eligió 11 comunidades rurales y
del norte que acogerán inmigrantes en el
otoño él dice hola buen día me llamo
rené gutiérrez méndez vivo en bogotá
colombia tengo 48 48 años perdón soy
contador público también tengo
experiencia en seguridad pues trabajé 20
años para una entidad del estado
colombiano en protección y vigilancia de
las prisiones mi esposa es enfermera y
estamos interesados y me gustaría
participar del proyecto hombre donde
puedo contar con más información que sea
confiable nuevamente en los ministerio
de inmigración tanto federal como de
cada provincia y en las embajadas si
están fuera de canadá en las órdenes
profesionales porque por ejemplo la
orden profesional de enfermeras una
esposa de él es de
de rim esa enfermera la orden
profesional enfermeras aunque después
del proceso es un poco más engorroso
continuamente reitera su necesidad de
personal así que puede ingresar a la
página de la del día del colegio de
enfermeras y ahí tendrá toda la
información muy bien leonard si tengo
acá un comentario sobre un reportaje me
parece que es medio antiguo es la
dopamina el químico del aprendizaje del
placer y el dolor comentaban es amena y
dice me encanta sus artículos por favor
si pueden escribir sobre la enfermedad
mielomeningocele que es una malformación
congénita una verdad que no conozco pero
podría investigar miel isla de la
mielina
lo que recoge el nervios y leonardo
gimeno chip aquí tengo un mensaje el
tema también canadá eligió 11
comunidades rurales y del norte que
acogerán inmigrantes en otoño dice
darling miranda quiero emigrar a canadá
como hago para ponerme en contacto con
el programa piloto rural
y de la provincia de de las provincias
del norte si alguien puede ayudarme
gracias repetimos la mejor manera es
poniendo esos datos por ejemplo canadá
11 comunidades rurales que permiten
inmigración o que dan la posibilidad de
emigrar a canadá o directamente en
inmigración canadá que es digamos el
portal de la inmigración de acción
federal hace poco hicimos la emisión
desde el salón del inmigrante no tuvimos
precisamente representantes de entidades
de regiones que hacen que llevan a cabo
trabajo rural y que invitan a los a los
potenciales inmigrantes oa gente que se
utiliza en el país que quiere radicarse
en esas zonas busquen la emisión del día
del salón del inmigrante y ahí van a
tener incluso los links de cada una de
esas instituciones bildu -la nos pueden
poner solo salón de la inmigración y le
va a salir segura mismo tiempo ese ese
reportaje antes de que se nos pase
demasiado el tiempo en los controles
técnicos hoy está de nuevo la marca
andrés de jean pierre dick til y como el
tiempo pasa justamente como agua entre
los dedos vamos
los temas que resaltamos hoy y ahora yo
creo que traspuso la tuve había pasado
y justamente yo había empezado a hablar
al principio después me di cuenta el
sobre el reloj este de la que mide los
cambios demográficos que se producen en
canadá pero minuto a minuto y lo
interesante ahí debe haber fotos
justamente es este para ver cómo está
funcionando ese reloj es un reloj
inventado es una herramienta inventada
por estadísticas canadá no sé si no se
puede ver no podemos en el reportaje
en el reportaje esta se puede graficar
bien la dice los tienen de reportajes
aquí porque yo creo que no le puse el
enlace a pierdo
el recinto estaba buscando esto cuando
hablaba en la primera lo puse el
comparativo dos gráficos para el
teléfono y subí mira ahí está
pero tienes que bajar y eso era por
ejemplo yo hice list hice una copia del
gráfico donde cuál es la población de
canadá hoy a las 9 de la mañana y daba
37 millones 592 mil 002 y dos horas más
tarde volvía el gráfico a ver qué cambio
había y ustedes se pueden dar cuenta
allí que de 0 0 al 2 pasó a 172 2 horas
más tarde y lo interesante si podemos ir
un poquito a la derecha no sé si se
puede ver el gráfico my stand son 6
gráficos con colores diferentes mostrar
los dos tienes que mostrar ropa que se
vea la diferencia ahí está por ejemplo
se lee el de la ader el de la izquierda
son los nacimientos el de la derecha
ponerle que sean las muertes de acá no
veo el rojo es la muerte a mí me
sorprendió porque recién estaba
chequeando el sitio ok y decía no sé
cuántos millones se controlan 78 y 77
que aquí se está perdiendo el programa
y entonces es super por ejemplo el
cuarto el quinto y el sexto son los
inmigrantes que llegan a canadá que van
contabilizando y los emigrantes adentro
de canadá es decir vos puedes saber en
tiempo real si hay una persona de la
ciudad de montreal que decidió irse a
vivir a la isla del príncipe eduardo o
si hay una familia en terranova que ha
perdido a uno de sus miembros o si hay
una persona en vancouver que acaba de
recibir a su familia de refugiados que
llegan en fin entonces es impresionante
esa herramienta y pueden ir y la
dirección está en el reportaje
justamente lo que decían ahora cuando ya
terminó de hacer el reportaje a las 11
de la mañana había 37 592 172 y si vamos
al sitio en este momento van a ver la
diferencia
ahí está el link para ir y vemos la
diferencia y ya yo 03 40 3 o sea desde
las 9 hasta ahora hasta las canadienses
y canadienses recién nacidos está
decidido dice nacimiento
arte inmigración emigración acción no
res no residentes no permanentes y la
migración inverna interna es tan buena y
está en bolsillo así que pueden ir ahí
los que quieran interesarse pone ahí hay
en una entrevista con un sociólogo de la
universidad de dalhousie bueno y los
invitamos a que visite nuestro sitio
internet y pueden consultar el tema de
leonora
louis tú nos hablas de la crisis de la
vivienda en quebec sí muy cortito
sabemos que todos los primeros de julio
canadá festeja su día nacional pero
además esa fecha en la provincia de
québec se da un fenómeno particular que
es el de muchísima gente que alquila
viviendas se dedica a mudarse porque
renueva nos renueva su contrato o
contrata otro otra vivienda y se va a
otro lugar este año lo que ha pasado es
que al día siguiente el 2 de julio la
hacer el frente de acción popular en
rediseño urbano fra plus
denunció que hay un faltante de vivienda
de alquiler en la provincia de québec
particularmente en las grandes ciudades
pero no solamente y esto se debe
básicamente a dos razones por un lado a
que ha bajado el nivel de construcción
de viviendas que se destinan en alquiler
se está construyendo mucho pero
viviendas de lujo dedicadas al mercado
de compraventa y por otro lado se está
invirtiendo mucho menos por parte de los
gobiernos en lo que se llama aquí en
esta provincia viviendas sociales encima
esas destinadas a gente de escasos
recursos y llama a las autoridades a
hacer algo para dar vuelta esta
situación urgentemente y hay que agregar
que la población canadiense está
envejeciendo en la quebequense no se
escapa entonces hay muchas
construcciones actualmente el cazón
dedicadas a los mayores y para los
promotores que construyen esos edificios
es muchísimo más rentable fabricar
construir este tipo de viviendas que
viviendas a precios módicos y entonces
en nuestro sitio internet
rcn puntos ya tú leonardo nos hablas de
un fallo que implica a facebook
así es faltado facebook una vez más en
este caso fue el miércoles pasado y uno
entraba a facebook
y veía en vez del lugar de las fotos
veía como una imagen rota eso que dice
que un error que no lo puede leer y
había un tag es decir la explicación que
lleva esa foto pero la explicación no es
el nombre de la foto ni lo que nosotros
pusimos como explicación es la
explicación que la inteligencia
artificial hace de la lectura de cada
una de estas fotos entonces
absolutamente así que hay una muestra y
en el sitio pueden ver yo tengo una
captura de pantalla del sitio de radio
canadá de facebook de radio canadá que
muestra en francés cuáles son los
nombres que había otorgado la
inteligencia artificial a esta a estas
fotos y bueno y allí hay toda una
disquisición con respecto a qué es lo
que hacen con esta información si sigue
inicial vendiendo la información para
que votantes y para manipular cosas todo
está dentro del sitio internet y bueno
pues yo los invito a escuchar una
entrevista que hice con una activista de
derechos humanos que estuvo de visita
aquí en montreal
es paloma de la torre díaz que trabaja
por el instituto de derechos humanos de
chile y bueno ella dice señala cuatro
puntos
de los que actualmente hay problemas en
de derechos humanos en chile de los
pueblos indígenas en la migración sur
sur los latinoamericanos en ese país el
tema medioambiental y el derecho de las
mujeres
leonardo en cinco segundos dos personas
que no habían para apareció nunca en
nuestro feed de facebook mar y la través
que bueno el programa marie vieja amiga
mío es ricardo arteaga santos y desde el
atlántico y saludos desde salvatierra
guanajuato y en guanajuato ismael samur
bueno eso fue todo el tiempo del que
disponíamos para este programa canadá en
las américas es café vamos a hacer una
petición para que lo alargue
chao
[Música]